Ciao a tutti
Avete mai pensato a quante volte avete
regalato 10 minuti
Avete mai pensato a quante volte
vi hanno rubato 10 minuti tipo che
avevate un appuntamento e la persona si
è presentata tardi
Vi chiedo adesso di iniziare a pensare a
cosa potete fare in 10 minuti
Ecco 10 minuti valgono circa 600 secondi
che sono lo
0,07% in una giornata
il 2022 è stato l'anno in cui ho perso
più treni e aerei della mia vita Ecco in
quel momento un minuto avrebbe fatto la
differenza Ho letto un articolo qualche
giorno fa che diceva Per capire il
valore di un mese Chiedi ad una madre
che ha partorito prematuramente Per
capire il valore di un secondo chiedi
una persona che ha evitato un incidente
per capire il valore di un millesimo di
secondo Chiedi ad una persona che ha
vinto la medaglia d'argento alle
Olimpiadi
io sono Chiara e nella mia vita ho
capito il valore del tempo a mie spese e
quanto è facile
sottovalutarlo praticamente due anni fa
quando credevo di aver passato troppo
poco tempo sulla terra Mi hanno mi hanno
diagnosticato una leucemia e Fabio
avanzato
quindi mi hanno detto che il mio tempo
che pensavo infinito era limitato come
me anche ad altri amici come Alessandro
che ogni giorno prima della diagnosi si
svegliava andava in piscina e si
allenava duramente per vincere la
medaglia d'oro dei mondiali di nuoto
Marta che iniziava a farsi i primi amici
alle scuole elementari o Francesca che
voleva diventare la più grande esperto
dei libri di Harry Potter o Chiara che
addirittura era nata il mio stesso
giorno dello stesso mese dello stesso
anno
ma duramente per diventare un grande
avvocato
ed è giusto è giusto perché alla fine a
5 10 15 20 anni pensi di vivere per
sempre
insieme a tutti questi amici dei reparto
in quel periodo ricevevamo sangue
ricevamo trasfusioni di sangue pensate
che ogni volta che mi recava in ospedale
per ricevere delle trasfusioni Aspettavo
anche 15 ore per due sacchi di sangue
per il mio peso ce ne vogliono due
quindici ore vi assicuro che con pochi
globuli rossi sono un attesa estenuante
vi racconto un giusto un aneddoto Nel
2020 novembre 2020 ero a Roma faceva
freddo
C'è stata una giornata in particolare
che è stata la mia tesa di sacchi di
sangue più lunga in assoluto eravamo tra
i 15 e le 20 ore Allora ero un po'
arrabbiata devo dire e avevo 18 anni e
ho detto Beh ora ho Instagram condivido
delle storie di Instagram
che cosa mi sta accadendo nessuno sapeva
che era in ospedale e iniziano a
rispondermi centinaia di amici centinaia
di conoscenti tutti che volevano venire
a donare in quel momento mi facevano
un'infinità di domande e allora mi sono
chiesta centinaia di persone vogliono
venire a donare per me in questo momento
sangue Però io sto aspettando 15 ore
come è possibile
eh A quel punto ho iniziato a
interrogarmi sulle cause delle mie
attese vi racconto due motivi uno i
giovani donatori sono sempre meno la
media di donatori di età di sangue in
Italia e di più di 46 anni
più di 46 anni si può donare tra i 18 e
i 60-65 anni
quindi se ci facciamo due conti ci
ritroviamo in un momento di ricambio
generazionale che non sta avvenendo
i donatori attuali non sono ricorrenti
Eh sì perché gli uomini possono donare
ogni 90 giorni quindi fino a 4 volte
l'anno e le donne in età fertile due
volte l'anno Quindi ogni 6 mesi e poi
invece come come quello che vi ho detto
prima quindi degli uomini
in questo momento vi sto raccontando
l'emergenza sangue in Italia Eh sì
perché non se ne parla molto
il sangue A cosa serve il sangue serve a
salvare pazienti che stanno facendo
delle terapie oncologiche come me ora So
bene a pazienti che devono fare delle
operazioni chirurgiche dalle più
sciocche a quelle più quelle più un po'
grandi quelli un po' più grandi e più
gravi a pazienti che sono affetti da
malattie autoimmuni avete mai sentito
parlare di anemia mediterranea i
pazienti talassi famosi pazienti tale
assemici proprio quei pazienti hanno
bisogno anche di una sacca di sangue una
trasfusione ogni due settimane
sono Chiara ho 21 anni
e l'impegno ogni giorno per azzerare
l'emergenza sangue in Italia nei
prossimi 10 anni
per farlo Ho creato rosso rosso è un
progetto che supporta ospedali e
associazioni dei donatori nell'aumentare
il numero di donatori e la loro
ricorrenza
Io e la mia squadra Barbara Federico
Iacopo Francesca Martina lavoriamo ogni
giorno per accompagnare i donatori nella
loro esperienza ogni viaggio è unico e
noi vi accompagniamo in questo viaggio
straordinario A me piace molto definirlo
viaggio
Stiamo costruendo la più grande anagrafe
dei donatori di sangue Europea per Under
35 una vera e propria rete di
solidarietà per contribuire ad azzerare
le emergenze sangue
col rosso ci impegniamo in un vero e
proprio innesto di cultura perché
crediamo che oggi
manca effettivamente la cultura della
donazione del sangue quindi raccontiamo
nelle comunità come scuole come
università
le aziende il grande impatto di questo
atto
per trasformi racconto vi racconto una
cosa per trasfondere una donna Una donna
in età fertile c'è bisogno del sangue di
un'altra donna giovane
e oggi purtroppo però per il numero dei
donatori e la disparità di genere
Purtroppo oggi i dati ci dicono che in
Italia per alcuni motivi le donne donano
di meno degli uomini non è un attacco
anzi
e quindi non si possono garantire non si
può garantire la compatibilità genetica
di questo l'obiettivo di rosso appunto è
garantire Le compatibilità genetiche
tramite le trasfusioni di sangue
Io oggi sono la prova che un'esperienza
negativa può diventare la mia passione
la mia passione è quella di aiutare a
migliorare percorsi di pre diagnosi
percorsi di prevenzione sono un
appassionata di innovazione sanitaria
quindi perché vi ho detto che 10 minuti
perché 10 minuti sono il tempo di una
donazione di sangue
10 minuti quindi possono salvare una
vita in 10 minuti potete donare del
tempo a chi sta aspettando ore e ore a
quelle 15 ore di cui vi parlavo prima
che tempo prezioso e il tempo che che a
loro serve per sopravvivere
Quindi mi auguro che questi minuti 10 e
ci siamo dedicati adesso a vicenda
possono servire a regalare più tempo a
chi non è abbastanza
Vi ringrazio molto
[Applauso]